thank you thanks to all of you for
coming having just come from Richmond
and Hurricane Isabel it's wonderful to
have these bright lights here we have no
electricity at home I want to I've been
asked to share with you briefly just out
the story of how I came to write this
book and then I want to tell you some
about the powerful story of Earl
Washington himself my full conscious
awareness of the case of Earl Washington
may have coincided with your first
awareness of the case it actually was
the airing in djenne on January the 11th
of 2,000 people frontline special called
a case for innocence and in that program
filmmaker Oprah Bikel documented the
cases of four men who were still in
prison even though DNA evidence
indicated that they were innocent of the
crimes they had committed Earl
Washington was one of those people
watching that program as a Virginian I
felt that this was a man that the
virginian-pilot
editorial page should champion clearly
Earle deserved an updated round of DNA
tests it had been some years since he
had had any and the sophistication of
DNA had changed considerably and I was
determined to add the voice of our
newspaper to those that were pressing
for him to get that new testing I don't
have a long history unlike many of you
of deep involvement in death penalty
issues like many Americans I suppose I
thought about the issue some in the
1970s in the 1980s as the number of
executions resumed in our country and
then grew and usually I thought of it
with a general discomfort but not with a
particularly focused or researched
opinion several things change that for
me one of them was the OJ Simpson case
as a political reporter for the
virginian-pilot
I did not do or have not done a great
deal of reporting about the criminal
justice system over the years but I had
done enough to know that regardless of
mr. Simpson's guilt or innocence a poor
or an educated person who had the degree
of evidence amassed against them that
had been amassed against mr. Simpson
almost certainly would have been headed
for death row and it seemed to me that
if life or death hinged on resources and
connections then this was not a system
that could be justified the second event
that pushed my personal thinking was the
execution of Roger Keith Coleman who you
may recall was executed in Virginia in
the early 1990s for the murder of a
Grundy Virginia housewife his case made
the cover of Time magazine because his
lawyers missed a critical filing by a
day and because of that certain habeas
hearings were not held that he should
have received I did some reporting on
that case including a trip out to the co
fils where he lived in the weeks before
his execution and what struck me in this
case was not so much the miscarriage of
justice
unlike many observers and probably some
of you in this room I walked away
thinking that probably Roger Coleman had
committed the murder of which he was
accused but what hit me on the night of
his death was that regardless of guilt
or innocence I was just struck by the
full horror of the state's
taking the life of a person I felt with
a clarity and perhaps this was because
this was a person that I had talked with
just a few days before but I felt with
the clarity that stooping to public
killing is not the way to build a Humane
Society a few years after that I began
writing editorials for the
virginian-pilot which is based in
Norfolk the pilot has a long history of
supporting issues involving racial
justice and so the editorial board
opposed the death penalty for many years
particularly as it was carried out in
the south but in the early 1980s when
Jay Harvey Wilkinson Jr who's now in the
4th Circuit Court of Appeals and perhaps
headed for the Supreme Court was briefly
the editorial page editor of the
virginian-pilot we changed that position
in 1998 not long after my switch from
reporting to editorial writing those of
us on the editorial board
realized one day as we were talking that
all of us had come to oppose the death
penalty even though we said two very
different places on the philosophical
spectrum and we decided particularly in
light of a rash of executions in
Virginia at that time that we were going
to switch our position back even though
we knew it would not be a popular change
in our community it turned out that I
wrote the editorial changing our
position and after that I was continuing
to write about specific cases at the
time that earl washington's plight came
to my attention his story is I believe
an amazing one though perhaps not
atypical
many of you probably know the surface
details by now Earl was an uneducated
Fauquier County farm hint hand who one
night in May of 1983 broke into the home
of an elderly neighbor intending to
steal a gun in the course of that
robbery mrs. hazel weeks woke up and
confronted him Earl does not have a
history of any violence prior to that
time or since that time he is in fact a
very peaceful person but that night he
had been drinking and he picked up a
chair and he beat her over the head with
it
he was arrested the next morning in a
field near her house the police when he
was arrested initially thought that
there had been an attempted rape this
was denied by mrs. weeks and that charge
was dropped but because that was the
belief are always questioned about every
unsolved sexual crime in that County and
the next and he confessed to all of them
the only one of those confessions that
stuck was the one involving Rebecca
Williams the 19 year-old mother of three
who had been killed the previous year in
neighboring Culpepper County the
Williams case is the only one for which
he was prosecuted and he later recanted
his confessions at his trial the
Commonwealth's Attorney said that Earl
knew things only the killer could have
known his attorney who was handling his
first capital case gave virtually no
rebuttal to that claim although as I
point out in the book there were
counterclaims to each of the arguments
that were raised each of the facts that
all supposedly new Washington was
convicted in February of 1984 and he
arrived on death row at Mecklenburg and
Virginia not long after that he remained
there for nine and a half years except
for a few weeks when he was transferred
to Richmond to the Spring Street
penitentiary for his scheduled execution
that year in 1985 he was nine days away
from death when a New York law firm
recruited at the last minute filed a
habeas appeal and the execution was
stayed some years later in January of
1994 on his last day in office
former governor Doug Wilder of Virginia
reduced Washington sentenced to life in
prison after a first DNA test turned up
a vaginal so an allele or a genetic
marker that could not have come from
Earl it was more than six years before a
second more sophisticated DNA test
determined that Earl was not the source
of semen found either on the vaginal
swabs or on the blue blanket on the bed
where Rebecca Williams was slain in
October of 2000 nine months after the
front line program then Governor Jim
Gilmore granted Earl an unconditional
pardon though no apology and a little
over four months later he was released
from prison having reached his mandatory
parole date in the break-in and wounding
of hazel weeks the state's foremost
sentencing expert said at that time that
Earl would probably have been released
eight or nine years earlier except for
the capital conviction and yet the state
of Virginia was determined that he would
stay within their purview as long as
possible
he in February hopefully will be
relieved a parole what I wanted to do
with this book was to pose an answer for
a general reader what must be after all
the DNA releases of recent years a
widespread question how is it possible
after all the supposed improvements in
the death penalty apparatus for an
innocent man to wind up on death row and
almost be executed many of you already
know the answer to that question and it
is why you were working so hard for
passage of the innocence Protection Act
if you are poor
a minority mentally challenged and
particularly if you have said had some
other run-in with the law in other words
if society views you as a person of
little value if you are an expendable
man as it were it is far easier than
most people could imagine to wind up on
death row and it is almost impossible to
get off once you are there we read about
a DNA release I think and it all sounds
so simple just you know sorry our bad
have a good life but in fact it has
until very recently been very difficult
even to get DNA testing once a person
has been convicted and once the results
are known there is not always a clear
path to freedom moreover as you know in
many death cases DNA simply does not
exist so many of the issues that faced
Earl Washington mental disability and
inadequate defense an appellate system
that is predisposed to upholding
politicians leery of taking political
risk still can produce and sustain a
false confession fiction in Earl's case
exoneration took DNA testing but it took
much more than that
it took a five-member team that stayed
with him for many years a member that
team is with us today and it also took
some incredible strokes of luck I'd like
to just tell you a few of them in the
summer of 1985 when he was scheduled to
die his habeas Appeals had not been
filed and he had no lawyer at that point
in time the state of Virginia did not
provide habeas attorneys no matter what
your mental capacity was you were
expected to write out for yourself or to
find a volunteer lawyer who would start
that process of the appeals activists
Murray Dean's whose son is with us today
was trying to find such an attorney but
having no luck and a fellow death row
inmate Joe Jarrett on Oh
using the prison library wrote and filed
the legal petition that resulted in
bringing in a prestigious New York law
firm the work of associate Eric Friedman
and others produced a last-minute stay
of the execution and Eric's continuing
work through the years
case has been vital to Earl's release
how many other people could count on a
fellow death row inmate filing an appeal
another pro bono attorney Bob Hall was
poring over the case file some months
later when he discovered what had been
missed at trial and also had been missed
by the prestigious New York law firm
what he found was that Earl Washington
had the wrong blood type for semen found
on the blanket without that discovery
after the trial was passed after initial
appeals were passed that discovery
without it all certainly would have died
another stroke of luck in 1993 a
temporary appointment in the Attorney
General's Office of Virginia resulting
from the fact that Mary Sue Terry had
left office to run for governor led to a
behind-the-scenes argument about
Washington's guilt I can assure you
there have been very few
behind-the-scenes arguments about the
guilt of a person or innocence of a
person already on death row in Virginia
coming out of the attorney general's
office but because a certain person had
been bumped up in rank this argument
occurred and it led in fact to the
timing of the first DNA test
the timing made it possible for Doug
Wilder the clemency petition to go to
Doug Wilder who was a former defense
attorney and was that still then and
still the nation's only elected black
governor who commuted to life in prison
the sentence on his last day in office
by any other timetable the person who
would have reviewed that claim would
have been a crime fighting governor
George Allen the likelihood is strong
that this would not have been granted
yet another stroke of luck in the spring
of 1999 if Paul Ferrara who is the head
of the state lab had not voluntarily
given 204 Bikel the results of a second
DNA test that had never been made public
by the Wilder administration a one can
speculate that once again there would
have been no new DNA testing and that
the case would not have come back to the
fore so yet another stroke of luck and
then finally if when governor Gill
more reviewed the results of the test
one of two DNA's found at the scene had
not belonged to a convicted rapist
already in the Virginia prison system
one can speculate that Washington might
never have been freed the American
system of jurisprudence of course
provides many protections against false
imprisonment there is the presumption of
innocence the guarantee of an attorney
and elaborate appeals process but the
advent of DNA has confirmed that the
system fails far more often than most
people would previously have imagined
what are some of the things that produce
a false conviction and how can they be
fixed there 3 stage is to bear in mind
interrogations trials and Appeals in
this case at the interrogation phase we
had a false confession for all the case
history of similar confessions in
Criminal Justice annals many citizens
still ask how is it possible that a
person would confess to a crime of this
magnitude that they did not commit and
in fact to this day the Commonwealth's
Attorney in Culpepper County maintains
that Earl Washington is guilty all
evidence to the contrary because he
firmly believes that a person would
never confess to this sort of crime
unless they were guilty most often over
the years when false confessions have
occurred police coercion has been
involved but there is no indication that
Earl was physically forced to confess
most likely this was a false confession
of a second sort growing out of
psychological intimidation of a person
who is in an extremely stressful
situation and wants to get out of that
situation and it's faced with police who
are eager to settle a case and do not
want to look at any sort of doubts that
might even be in their own minds about
whether the person is actually telling
the truth
it's clear that for interviews that the
Fauquier County police had very little
understanding of mental retardation or
of the value of having prisoner
advocates present to have to help a
person during an interrogation who has
an indication of mental challenge
a powerfully needed reform in this
country is the videotaping minimum the
audio taping of all confessions and
murder trials Illinois has just passed
such a reform and many other states we
hope will follow suit in this case in
researching the the case I had to rely
almost heavily and in some cases almost
exclusively on police notes for an
interpretation of what had occurred at
pivotal moments hours of interrogation
were reduced to a few brief sentences in
those reports so one can speculate on
how accurate what I was reading is it's
essential that those reviewing the
authenticity of a confession be able to
see and hear what was actually asked and
said false confession or false
convictions can also come about due to
unscrupulous police of course there is
no extensive evidence of misconduct in
the public record on this case although
I understand that the release of certain
records under court order to Earls
attorneys in the ongoing civil case is
turning up some striking new information
and we will hear more about that later
but even in the earlier record there is
some evidence of questionable actions
for instance hair is taken from a shirt
that had a tenuous connection to the
crime scene were never tested for a
comparison with URLs although they had
been tested for every other hour person
who is being considered as the possible
culprit in this crime at the end also
the state lab specifically asked that
the hairs be tested but they were not at
that point in time the police felt that
they had their man and they simply did
not send the hairs back to the state lab
after that the hairs disappeared I also
found that the description of mrs. weeks
given by the first officer on the scene
after the break-in changed dramatically
over the course of the year on the night
of the break and officer Danny Zebes
wrote that mrs. weeks was in the
bathroom with her daughter-in-law
getting cleaned up when he arrived a
year later in a pre-sentence report he
claimed that he found her quote
partially on the bed naked and bleeding
that account is at odds with the memory
of her son and it's at odds totally at
odds with his
your account the night after the
break-in but the more graphic
description is what was cited by state
officials when they were explaining to
reporters wire all did not receive an
earlier release the case points also to
the desperate need for well-qualified
attorneys in capital cases something
that the innocence Protection Act seeks
ironically as you know in capital cases
the quality of the defense counsel is
often far superior in the appeal stage
when very little can be done to change
what has already occurred then at the
trial when it is much easier to affect
outcomes
Washington's attorney who is now a
circuit court judge in Virginia
was simply in over his head in this case
he did not offer possible explanations
for the things that are all supposedly
new he did not for instance emphasize
the many things that were wrong in
Earl's confession Earl said that Rebecca
Williams was black when she was white he
said no one else was in the apartment
when her two small children were just
inside the front door he said that he
took off a halter top but there was no
clothing of that description at the
crime scene
he said he cut himself at the crime
scene but no blood was found he
identified a shirt later found by the
victim's mother as his but no one ever
explained how the police could have
searched the room where she was slain
for hours and not seen a bloody shirt
lying on an open drawer Oh numbers of
course did not tell the whole story but
they do give you an indication of the
imbalance in the trial the
Commonwealth's Attorney's opening
statement took up 11 pages of the
transcript the defense opening statement
took up three the prosecution called 14
witnesses and their testimony consumed
162 pages the defense called two
witnesses are all and one of his sisters
the closing statement of the prosecutor
was nine pages long the defense
attorneys closing statement was two
pages long and could be summed up fairly
by saying you have heard all the
evidence now it is up to you
even Earl's defenders seemed overwhelmed
by the weight of a confession that no
one had forced him to make while
substantial improved
it's have been made in the guidelines
for representation in capital cases
since 1983 the quality of representation
still varies enormous ly in these cases
then finally at the peel appeal stage
there simply must be more skeptical
review of capital convictions certainly
than has occurred in Virginia hopefully
the groundswell of DNA releases is
beginning to alter the some but not
enough courts particularly need to be
skeptical of any conviction that is
based on a single eyewitness a jailhouse
informant or confession but even more
there needs to be a process in every
state by which new evidence of innocence
can be introduced post-conviction
limiting post-conviction review to the
gubernatorial clemency process is in
twining politics and justice in a way
that is not fair to either the details
of Earl Washington's case are unique but
what they reveal about the death penalty
process its strengths and its weaknesses
is not unique it is almost impossible to
review the details of this case and
realize what a miraculous thing it is
that he was ever freed and not come away
believing that we have executed in this
country other expendable men I hope that
this case and this book will foster
understanding and reform
I would like to introduce you now to Bob
Hall who can bring us up to date with
the exciting details to the extent that
he is able to it's allowed to by law on
what is happening with the civil case
and Bob for those of you who have seen
an attorney who's under a protective
order plucked that fine line between
discussing what I'm not at liberty to
and what we know from multiple other
sources besides the protected documents
let me bring you an update and and every
reason for Margaret to go to a second
edition because in the course of a civil
suit to provide compensation for Earl
for the years he spent on death row for
the privilege he got of being at the row
in sight of and sound of the electric
chair as it was tested for his his
electrocution as a man deprived of the
basic fundamentals of opportunity and
the right to penal institutional
education and a man who lived under the
threat of death on it on an ongoing
basis for way too many years and as a
man who spent a total of 18 plus years
in prison for for the week's crime which
rather classically would have provided
him incarceration for five years had he
met the standards as first offender this
dividing line may be hard for me to
honor let me try
Margaret has touched on the issues of
the false confession in the confession
that was admitted into evidence the
reading of which took approximately
15-20 minutes but was based upon hours
of interrogation was no reference to the
fact that Earl identified the victim as
black when she was white that didn't
appear until a memorandum was prepared
by the interrogators to provide to the
prosecutor to have him understand the
background and it would help you when
this document becomes public and it is
one that
was provided before the protective order
was imposed Earl was your victim black
or white um she was black Earl are you
sure no I'm not sure okay Earl
was she white she was white the same
with the people in the in the apartment
a three year old daughter an eight month
old baby in a crib playpen rather just
inside the front door how did you get in
I kicked the door in no signs of any
marks at all on the door and apparent
consensual entry and more startling the
presence of two eyewitnesses who said
that they observed an african-american
male with the beard standing outside the
victims apartment within minutes of her
arrival back at that door bleeding from
38 stab wounds
by the way Earl said he stabbed her once
or twice two eyewitnesses who observed a
man well enough to provide a composite
sketch that was published in the
Culpeper star exponent and used as the
basis for the interrogation of people
who saw the composite and said I think I
know who that is a trial of Earl Earl
Washington in which neither of these
eyewitnesses were called to testify for
the prosecution that doesn't take too
much to read between the lines that Earl
must have been exhibited to these people
by photograph or in person at one of his
preliminary hearings and they must have
been asked you recognize him and the
answer must have been either no or I
can't be sure because had they given
identification of Earl Washington as the
man they saw at the door they would have
testified at the trial this was a case
based upon a confession with a single
corroboration which was part of the
confession this shirt this mysteriously
appearing shirt that was found in the
Chester drawers after the chest was
removed
from the home by the family when the
family the dad and the children can no
longer live there a shirt that had in it
hair fragments hair fragments that were
submitted for diagnostic testing by the
state crime lab by the way state crime
lab returned those hairs after their
analysis and photographs to the
investigators and those hairs have been
lost but Earl's hairs were harvested
head ah the beard well Errol didn't have
a beard he might get a week or twos
growth and it could be called a beard
but they harvest is what little they
could by extraction of a few face hairs
and coarse pubic hairs for testing and
they were at one time in the lab for
comparison to the hairs found in the
shirt pocket and a directive that
appears in the laboratory report hairs
of Earl Washington not tested per
instructions from the investigator and
what has intervened between the
harvesting of his hairs and the
direction not to test them the final
typed confession sign by Earl Washington
presumably and will here during the
civil suit and in many way the civil
suit is a blessing because we have wide
discovery available to us we'll hear an
explanation why those hairs were not to
be tested our assumption until there is
a logical explanation if there be one is
don't mess up my confession with your
science there's another bit of science
that I can talk to you only in a limited
sense at the scene blood everywhere on
one blanket blood that had a marker that
could not have been the victims
blood that was found only in people of
African descent and then in only 10
percent of them a marker which led the
investigators to believe that the
assailant had cut himself and bled on
that blanket that caused them to canvass
emergency departments emergency rooms
within a 50-mile radius looking for
anyone that may have come in for
treatment because there was a lot of
blood on that blanket and it had this
marker and it was not the victims when
our old Washington confessed and blood
was drawn from him for testing it was
tested it didn't have that marker there
was a meeting between the investigators
the prosecutor and a member from the lab
that finding which one police officer to
that point had noted was so significant
to the case that he asked the lab to
test it again to make sure and it was
confirmed that it was present after the
arrest of rural Washington because he
didn't have that marker there was this
meeting and the lab report now says the
findings with respect to that marker are
inconclusive
what you will find as you read
Margaret's book and what you will find
if you follow this case through its its
civil proceedings and we have a trial in
March of next year is once the Fauquier
County Virginia Sheriff's Department
obtained his confession to this Culpeper
County crime by the way a crime that in
foggy air they didn't have all the
details of and turned him over to call
pepper for further interrogation and
investigation but I think you'll find
and Margaret sets the stage very clearly
Rebecca
Williams died in June of 1982 until May
of 1983 the investigation had gone
nowhere
there were 11 identified suspects
but the prosecution of any claim against
them was wanting essential ingredients
usually the forensic ingredients there
wasn't a makeable case on any one of the
eleven all of whose hairs had been
harvested and tested and compared to the
hairs in the shirt pocket when that
phone call came in Culpeper from the
Fauquier County Sheriff's Department we
have a man here his name is earl
washington and he has confessed to that
murder case you are working you can
almost feel it's almost palpable this
sigh of relief that this case that had
so perplexed the Culpeper authorities
had now been solved and when earl was
delivered to them Earl can you show us
where it happened
yes sir and they put him in the car and
they drove him around Culpepper and they
took him to every apartment complex that
they could and when they drove in where
it happened and they said is this the
place no sir and they took him out again
and they drove him around to another
apartment project and eventually they
came back to the crime scene
take another look is this the place no
sir and out again and finally back and
the words of the street trooper who was
present in the car I'll take a look over
there at that place is that the place
well no sir it's this one over here
implanting in his mind that he was at
the correct place
every inconsistent piece of evidence
with URLs participation in this claim
got either ignored ie the eyewitness
testimony got adapted ie the lab report
on inconclusive findings or got don't
test that and Earl went down the road
towards execution they were
institutionally invested in Earl's guilt
from the moment he was turned over to
them and that is one of the greatest
hazards margaret has suggested some
opportunities and I hope this lawsuit of
ours for compensation for Earl
helps march down that road some
opportunities to avoid this one I think
is essential and certainly in capital
cases is a recordation of the
interrogation not the confession the
interrogation that leads up to the
confession and the confession because
but for luck and God knows our always
lucky he was lucky that there was DNA
material left for testing a number of
the specimens were no longer capable of
producing testable DNA he was lucky that
Ophir de Cal got interested in his case
and we never would have known that he
miss identified the race of the victim
at one time until one of the state
troopers at one of the hearings let it
slip out that he had done so these
interrogations must be recorded if
there's to be fundamental fairness let
me rest will take some some questions I
hope we for which we have some answers I
will answer that which the protective
order allows me to but I come to you
from a state that has made three
important declarations in the past
fifteen years one twenty one days after
a conviction is final actual innocence
is your relevant to and this is an
editorial writer from a different paper
that execution of an occasional innocent
is a reasonable price to pay to make
sure that we execute all of the guilty
and the third is the message that
notwithstanding our old Washington's
pardon and his exoneration there is no
apology there is no statement of his
innocence and in fact to this point the
prosecutorial authorities in Culpepper
insisted that they had the right one and
the message there is I am so embarrassed
the victim lived long enough to tell two
police officers her husband and a
neighbor it was a single assailant and
when he was first in 1993 the DNA was
inconsistent with Earl's participation
and again with his exoneration by
improved DNA testing in the year 2000 we
had the right guy when we had Earl
Washington we know that he did it and
the message there for all of us is don't
worry about the perpetrator still being
out there our blinders are on so
securely we don't need to look for him
anymore
because we are so persuaded that the
facts of Earl's guilt are so
overwhelming when there are in fact not
thank you so much
[Applause]
Thank You mr. Hall before we go to have
a brief question and answer I'd like to
introduce mr. Wayne Smith from the
Justice Project thank you John
in the course of human events and like
in the struggle for justice movements in
America have been blessed to have had
regular people display remarkable acts
of courage and faith in a struggle
against slavery as we all know there
were individuals like Dred Scott
Sojourner Truth Harriet Tubman and of
course Frederick Douglass and many
others in the struggle for civil rights
in America there were people like Fannie
Lou Hamer dr. Martin Luther King Murli
Medgar Evers and still many others black
white rich and poor and now we come to
the struggle against the injustice of
the death penalty as it is presently
administered in this country we are
blessed to have people like Kirk
Bloodsworth and Earl Washington indeed
despite the incredible struggle that
they've gone through we are blessed to
have them because we can learn from
their experiences in some ways they
personify the injustice by having
incompetent counsel by not having in
some cases the preservation or as Bob
Hall said so well the luck of preserving
and having genetic material it is
paramount that these laws that the
protections are put in place at the
state and federal level Kirk and I are
here to acknowledge not only the
impressive story that happened in
Virginia is written in Margaret's book
but this is a national phenomenon and we
are committed to the pursuit of justice
and are here today to simply affirm that
but to salute the good work that you've
done and the contribution that Earl's
story has given all of us this is Kirk
Bloodsworth my friend and colleague Kirk
was a Marine who served this country
with great disdain
he as most of you know was wrongly
convicted sentenced to death for the
murder of a nine-year-old girl that he
never did and after spending two years
on death row nine in prison he finally
through luck was exonerated but even
after being exonerated for 10 whole
years the shadow of doubt remained
prosecutors didn't really acknowledge
that in fact he was innocent
they equivocating and just two weeks ago
as I hope many of you read in
yesterday's Washington Post by former
FBI director William sessions the
prosecutor called Kirk to let him know
that in fact they had a match after all
these years when they could have easily
tested this genetic material they didn't
but the prosecutor called Kirk to
apologize and in her own way she said
let's meet and they met in a Burger King
parking lot to give this man justice
this is not the American Way but Kirk
bears no hostility he is committed to
the pursuit of justice and he is
committed to telling the truth ladies
and gentlemen Kirk Bloodsworth if we
don't pass solid legislation in this
country to preserve the evidence to have
access to DNA testing to have competent
counsel there's going to be many and I
emphasize this to everyone
many Earl Washington's in this world the
things that Miss Epps had said
concerning his case is not some the
thing that just happens the appalling
things that mr. Hall was telling us
about that's the price we pay for
democracy in this country bull we have a
right in this country to have the guilty
punished in
set free and until we do that like I say
we're going to have Kirk Bloodsworth
sander old Washington's across this
country that should never happen pass
the legislation now and Virginia get on
a stick it's time he's got to stop
putting her head in the sand thank you
[Applause]
we're now ready to take some questions
if anyone has any for Margaret or Bob
Morgan I was wondering if you think that
this case or a Washington's case and
perhaps some of the others like Kirk's
have changed anything in Virginia and
Virginia is second only to Texas in
terms of the number of executions this
well I think they've had an impact but
not nearly so much as I would have hoped
it seems that the courts are being a
little bit more cautious and sending
things through the legislature has now
said has created a procedure where you
can get post-conviction DNA testing
under certain circumstances but they are
debating a way to create that for cases
in which DNA does not exist and it
appears to me that the guidelines
they're thinking of putting upon it are
so strict that it would almost never if
ever be met it was all so disconcerting
to me not long ago to be interviewing a
man who is extremely influential in the
legislature in terms of criminal justice
issues and to hear him say of course you
know or Washington was guilty I sent him
a copy of the book
have been writing the book I imagine
you've dealt with the Coleman case but
in reading the book I couldn't help but
notice as I was reading through it that
well this is something that ought to be
used to test roger Coleman's DNA would
you comment on that yes we have those of
you who may not know the case that I
mentioned earlier of Roger Keith Coleman
who was executed about a decade ago DNA
testing was done at the time but it's
not so sophisticated as the testing
that's available now and his genetic
material sits in the laboratory in
California where it could be tested but
the courts have said that his attorneys
have well a group of newspapers brought
a suit to try concluding the pilot to
try to get this tested and we lost it's
now before the governor who is being
urged to allow this testing to go
forward why if there is any chance of
proving that a person either you know
did or did not commit the crime why
should we not be able to have that
information if it exists so far we're
still waiting in the course of your
reporting how cooperative with your
authorities and what where did you get
any did you hear from them after the
book was published what they thought
about it most of the authorities were
not very cooperative most of the police
were not there were a few people who
were his original interrogator in
Fauquier County talked with me about it
and he was convinced that he had done
the right thing but it was an
illuminating interview because he could
take the the train or at least what had
been recorded in the police notes and he
would say there would be a point where
Earl would have said oh well I didn't do
that and then they would say are you
sure you didn't do that and he would say
okay I did that in talking to this
interrogator he said now see look at
that you see right there that's how it
was he would it was just once you told
him that really he really had done it he
would say yes he had and he took that as
proof that of Earl's guilt I think many
others would see it in a different light
for the most part the authorities were
not very cooperative but a few were
yeah to the book well I've been told
that the Culpepper town council likes
the book very much but I'm not sure
about the police officers in town it
strikes me that public police officers
and attorneys and prosecutors in office
I think know very little about people
who have limited intellectual ability am
I correct in my impression yes there's
very little training and professional
police courses about this and now that
we have people getting college in junior
college degrees in criminology could
there be a push to have this included in
their professional I think that there
should be I hope there is being though
another officer who was willing to be
interviewed who set on the town police
in Warrenton which is in Fauquier County
and who questioned Earl about some of
the other cases that he was never
prosecuted on when I interviewed him he
had on his wall all sorts of
documentation of courses that he had
gone through in terms of interrogation
and he was very proud of that and I said
did any of those talk about mental
retardation and he said well no none of
them did so there's a big gap there yes
we're talking about the 21 day project
and the group that's reviewing that one
is I think the disturbing things is that
for people who do not have DNA evidence
if you have confessed to the crime you
are not available for to have your
evidence of innocence reintroduced and I
wonder how you feel knowing that Earl
did confess in was innocent and how
that's affected your take on the 21 day
I think that's one of the big problems
with that legislation another problem
with it is it says in effect that this
cannot be rehired if any reasonable
person could assume clewd that the
person was actually guilty well that's
an impossible standard there is always
some reasonable person somewhere who
could come to the conclusion that they
were guilty and to have that standard to
me means
no one will be able to access that
legislation figure out people's motives
but I'm always curious in these cases of
wrongful conviction if the authorities
appear to have known they had the wrong
person that just really really wanted a
conviction or really thought they had
the right person and just want to ignore
the science I mean I'm just wondering if
either you were the lawyer have any
thoughts about well I would be
interested in Bob's take on that it's of
course hard to know when you are not
there but I've been with Earl now in a
number of different settings and in
comfortable settings he's very you know
easy to talk with and whatever but in in
settings where that are very stressful
it's very hard for him to say much and
it's hard for me to believe that police
officers did not realize in the sense
what they were doing but of course I
wasn't there I can't say that with
certainty Bob do you have him except
sorry the inability to accept the
factual innocence of someone that you've
held in prison for almost 20 years
probably has three bases one is of the
prosecutor who now insists and still
insists on Earl's guilt has a
relationship with the police officers
whom he feels he needs to protect he
doesn't want what is he was not the
prosecutor a girl the prosecutor girl
has retired from that office so he has
his officers to look after in terms of
of the potential embarrassment of it
number two if you say that he was
innocent then you have to respond to
questions about how you convicted him
and how you held him so long and by
saying he's still guilty you shut down
the door on adding until Margaret comes
along and say well what do you really
rely on if the DNA has exonerated him
and and the third is this sense that
this trial that he had
within 21 days of its conclusion is the
final statement that the law ought to
allow about this because we need
finality for the victim's family well
Clifford Williams the husband of Rebecca
Williams is at pain for the want of
knowledge he has turned to Eric Friedman
who sent him on to talk with us and
readings and I met with Clifford and as
the husband of the victim he feels
betrayed by the system because they
won't tell him what this ongoing
investigation is producing and I say to
see the system fail that way and on the
mental retardation and our police
trained frankly if they follow good
interrogation practices the mental
limitations of the person being
interrogated may may not be as important
if they follow tell me what happened in
your own words tell me what you did but
when you start to provide the words and
the inferences and let them know that
the conclusions or statements say
they've made are wrong then the
retardation becomes a big factor when
you started the book were you as
convinced of Earl's innocence as you are
now um I was convinced of his well I
guess what I'm I'm trying to think what
I actually started the book where I draw
that line when I first started looking
at the case of course what I knew about
it was what I'd seen on frontline so at
that point I was not as convinced and I
was really by the time he was freed I
was convinced that he was innocent but
when I started writing this book I
wanted to approach it without those
blinders I wanted to say I wanted to go
to the people who had another view and
really listen to what they had to say
and try to understand how they had
formed the conclusions they had formed
and all along the way I was willing for
them to give me evidence that in fact he
was guilty but no one could and in fact
I found many misconceptions the
prosecutor now the current prosecutor
who continues to believe in
guilt told me for instance that Earl
confessed the night that he was arrested
in the hazel weeks crime out in the
field where he was arrested confessed to
the Rebecca Williams murder that was
simply not true and the people the
police officers confirmed that that was
not true but that was part of the
thinking of the man who is now saying to
the world that our Washington is guilty
yes you mentioned that we generally like
to all those who are dispossessed and
who are ignorant or illiterate or
whatever and then you also talk about
your own experience having gotten to
know someone who was killed in house on
death row and that changed your
perception and it seems to me that the
OJ Simpson trial is a perfect point of
that I cannot imagine any reason why the
prosecution would not have gone for the
death penalty except for the fact that
they knew Americans don't like to kill
folks they feel like they know do you
agree with that um if ever there was a
case calling for the death penalty it
would have been the oj k what do you
think he was guilty or innocent well i
guess my thinking on that was again not
in terms of guilt or innocence because I
really didn't know but I did know enough
about the criminal justice system to
believe that you could not have so much
evidence against you if you had no
resources and expect to be freed so it
was a point at which I came to
understand which I guess already
understood to a degree but more
graphically the difference in justice
that is available based on resources
thank you all once again I'd like to
thank everyone for coming there are
copies of Margaret's book outside and
she has graciously agreed to autograph
those so please pick them up I'd like to
thank Kirk for coming up miss
Quisenberry for coming up much
appreciated and of course to Bob
Marguerite's and thank you everyone